the cleanest use of Napalm involves a
simple yet potent concoction a mixture
of Styrofoam and gasoline this
combination is easily accessible and
serves as a makeshift variant of Napalm
when styrofoam is introduced to gasoline
a chemical reaction occurs breaking down
the styrofoam and transforming it into a
gel-like substance the reaction causes
the air trapped within the styrofoam to
escape resulting in a sticky and gooey
substance with high flammability this
mixture poses a significant Hazard as it
can adhere to most surfaces including
skin and then ignite on contact with the
source of fire its ability to burn and
cling to objects made it a formidable
weapon during the second world war where
it found utility in various Warfare
scenarios while the styrofoam gasoline
Napalm blend can create a messy
aftermath its Effectiveness as a highly
flammable substance demands caution and
ensures its place as a historical weapon
of significance